Matthew it sounds to me like you have a
lot of things you want to say to your
mother but feel that you cannot yeah
well sometimes I find it's helpful to
role play in the safety of this office
so that it can prepare you for those
real life conversations that sound like
something we can do
yeah all right all right great so I'll
play your mother you be you and just try
it okay um well mom um I wish you could
focus your attention more on me because
I feel like it that's great why don't we
start over and do it for real I was
doing it that was for real that was for
real
yeah I didn't believe you know I didn't
believe any of it okay so I'm really
your mother the more realistic this is
the more beneficial it will be for you
okay okay
hey mom no I hey mom I just really wish
Adam that was a start over hey mom what
where are we right now um we're in my
mother's kitchen no oh okay no I'm okay
I'm helping my mom make dinner I'm in
the kitchen helping my mom make dinner
great okay hoping mother with dinner
we're in the kitchen after something you
do in the kitchen
okay Oh me that you're helping your
mother hey mom I want to talk to you
about decided you're making pancakes
um old-timey better you making some
banner better okay fine it's a huge bowl
you got 15 friends coming over later and
they all want to roll it does it really
matter what's in the bowl well you don't
think it matters I know I only wanna
roleplay my honor you're being the
doctor not being the patient tell me how
it works doctor I'm sorry I the first
time I believe you all they're really
yeah
okay okay okay stir your huge bowl okay
listen mom I don't like it when we're
together did you stop just hard to stop
hold on I'm just gonna show you how it's
done okay okay you be my mother I'll be
me Oh Betty you [ __ ] she's doing [ __ ]
oh wow that's that
that's what you want to say to your mom
no that was all for you [ __ ] that's our
time [ __ ]